alice rencontre bob est instantanément
c'est le coup de foudre les débuts de la
relation sont idylliques et alice ne
cesse de dire bob à quel point elle le
trouve beau puis le plus bel homme que
je n'ai jamais rencontré bob est content
et c'est peut-être la première fois
qu'il fait un tel effet à quelqu'un ça
commence à consolider sa confiance en
lui
en tout cas en son potentiel de
séduction dans le regard d'alice il est
beau c'est agréable
arrive le jour où alice va lui présenter
sa famille alors qu'elle lui fait
visiter la maison de ses parents
bob tombe sur une photo du père d'alice
quand il était jeune horreur
c'est son portrait craché tout d'un coup
le compliment d'alice perd toute valeur
ce n'est pas je suis beau paquebot avec
effroi c'est qu'elle a un complexe
d'electre et que je lui rappelle son
père
la question que je pose ici c'est quand
est ce qu'un compliment transmet
effectivement une information pertinente
quand est ce que ça nous apprend quelque
chose sur ce qu'on est en l'occurrence
plaire à alice parce qu'il ressemble à
son père ce n'est pas ce que j'appelle
une information pertinente quant à la
potentielle beauté de bob plaire parce
qu'on ressemble à un modèle social c'est
à dire à une convention esthétique kif
énorme dans la société
ce n'est pas si différent au fond ça
peut être un peu plus rassurants sur
notre capacité à plat en général mais en
tout cas ça ne dit pas grand chose de ce
que c'est qu'être beau la société dit
aux garçons voilà le type de fille qu'il
faut désirer
les garçons opine les filles dans de
ressembler à ce type les garçons les
désirs qui se sont éclatés tu tapes et
absurdement de son côté alice éclaté
parce que bob ne cesse de le dire
qu'elle est intelligente
quelle est la personne la plus
intelligente qui connaissent
est-ce que ce complément à plus de sens
je ne suis pas sûr a priori on pourrait
imaginer que pour mesurer l'intelligence
il faut pouvoir comprendre
d'intelligence donc en un sens être
aussi intelligent que la personne qu'on
juge intelligente
c'est un peu comme si quelqu'un deux
nuls en mathématiques disait un
mathématicien d'être super fort en maths
pour le mathématicien qu'un pense à ça
ne veut rien dire si omer dia stephen
hawking book in med z super intelligent
on peut se demander quel sens d'avoir
cette phrase dans ce cas bob dit en fait
la liste tué au moins aussi intelligente
que moi dirait quelqu'un je suis assez
intelligent pour savoir que tu es
intelligent aussi est toujours un
compliment
pas sûr et puis c'est tout de même une
remarque purement symbolique seul alice
peut savoir ce que c'est que d'éprouver
son intellect et sa puissance mentale en
général si elle se sent bête parce
qu'elle ne parvient pas à raisonner
comme elle le souhaite
ce n'est pas le fait de paraître
intelligente qui va changer quoi que ce
soit et si cela ne veut en fait rien
dire de plus que tu donnes l'impression
d'être intelligente je ne suis pas sûr
que ce soit très intéressant est-ce que
je crois qu aucun compliment n'a de sens
non il y en a un qui est tout à fait
sensé tu es gentil et bien oui seul
autrui détient la vérité quant à ma
gentillesse et dans mêmes envies des
seuls alice de dire above qu'il est un
chouette petit ami attentionné seul bob
petit réalise qu avec l qui se sent
moins seul là en l'occurrence il y à une
information transmise
une information à laquelle je ne peux
pas avoir accès sans le regard d'autres